underwater photography is a challenge
we're limited by air
light time depth animal behavior just to
name a few of the constraints
i like this image of me diving because
it's uh it captures the strobes
illuminating the wreath
at depth the wavelength of red is
absorbed and the ocean appears of
blue-gray
but with the addition of light i'm able
to reveal vibrant colors
in the galapagos islands i was on an
assignment focusing on biodiversity in
sharks
as we began to swim back to the boat i
observed a large aggregation of sea
stars along the vast open sandy bottom
the galapagos is known for its spire
diverse marine ecosystems it's full of
mystery and entry
but the colors of these sea stars are
natural but they're revealed
by the light of the stroke
wildlife photography is about hours days
weeks maybe even years of patience
followed by an instant of action in this
photograph of a juvenile frigate bird
diving to catch a fish is an example of
that it was a behavior i observed and
spent two days waiting in shallow water
with the lens pre-focused the strobes
above and below the water
frigate birds never land in the water
these birds are unbelievable they
accelerate downward focusing on the fish
when they get near the surface they
virtually stall
they place their head in the water they
switch between surface vision underwater
vision
without blinking catch the fish and then
fly away all
in an instant i stopped the lens snapped
the picture
looked it back and with a little bit of
luck i managed to get
just this photo here there are also
unexpected moments
within the tentacles of a jellyfish is a
school of juvenile trevally that seeks
shelter
if you look closely you can see them
right in the tentacles to capture this
image i
inverted myself under the water giving
the fish's perspective of what
life must look like through the waves
into the clouds in the sky
oftentimes i collaborate with scientists
and i often experiment with other ways
to visualize marine environment
this photo is one of my colleagues using
a fluorescent strobes to survey the
coral reefs
the psychedelic colors emitted by
fluorescence light showcase another way
of looking at art in nature
while at the same point the colors may
lead to a deeper understanding about the
health of our corals
sometimes i'm on assignments in
indonesia or other places around the
world
diving with scientists setting out to
find and discover new possible species
of coral
this is one that's being described as a
flower-like pattern that is unlike any
other known species
and we're inspired by the work of
scientists at mit sea grant
where we're experimenting with a variety
of photomicroscopy image making
techniques
this image was created adding a drop of
milk on the slide
and just filming the dynamic flow
visualization created by this clion
or petrito pod people often ask what is
it like to travel with you on assignment
and actually the most stressful part of
my job is so nervously checking all the
luggage and bringing all the equipment
everywhere
i need to go and just to give a sense of
the kind of equipment that i have these
are the housings that are all broken
apart
as they're ready to be cleaned and
assembled
on this one magical day working with a
team of scientists naturalists and boat
captains i slipped into the water with a
wetsuit snorkel
360 multi-camera system looking to film
what we thought was a basking shark
moving on the surface
to my surprise instead of encountering a
basking shark it was an enormous 3000
pound great white shark
later identified as large march it did
the only thing i know how to do which is
keep the camera stable and captured 17
glorious seconds of footage from tip to
tail
that can be viewed an immersive virtual
reality experience
photography really has the power to
change our understanding of the world
around us
and it is my lifelong goal to use the
artistry of underwater photography to
transform public perception
that sparks our imagination inspires
conservation and builds a local
stewardship about the extraordinary
underwater wildlife
and to connect residents in new england
with the local marine wildlife
just off our shores